what about pay like are these jobs
paying more than let's say their
counterparts and other tech companies
are they paying more than like working
out like a small business what do you
see there they're paying enough to lure
away the top talent from a lot of the
top companies everyone wants to know how
to get a job in crypto um
how big is the market like like when you
think about people trying to get a job
are there tons and tons of open rolls or
just there's a lot of demand but not a
lot of supply yeah there's a lot of
demand there's a lot of supply i think
uh if you do a linkedin search hold me
to this but i believe there's over a
hundred thousand people uh working in
the bitcoin and crypto industry right
now coinbase they employ
five thousand plus people they're hiring
a bunch of people this year and even as
some of these fintech companies are
starting to lay off people it seems like
coinbase and some of these others are
really absorbing the talent talk to me
about uh this idea of like who's
actually transitioning is this just a
software developer at facebook is the
one that ends up getting a job or is it
people from all walks of life yeah we've
seen people from all walks of life i
think top talent is leaving fintech and
legacy finance
to join the industry lawyers accountants
etc but then all the way down to you
know customer service i think some of
the most interesting stories we know
someone pretty well who's in his mid-50s
um he's a former funeral director and
now he's working in social media in the
crypto industry um another guy is a
college dropout he was selling insurance
for state farm now works for bitcoin inc
and then you hear stories of people like
the 13 year old kid that's like a salon
a dev uh he might need to pick it up a
little bit based on
recent developments but uh there's
there's a spot for everyone in the
industry as you guys have worked with i
don't know at this point over a thousand
people i think have gotten a job yeah um
what are some of like the tips or tricks
that you tell folks in terms of like
they can increase the probability of
success in transitioning yeah there's a
number of things one is just find out
what you're passionate about uh you know
if you're a bitcoin only then go look
for a bitcoin only company so number one
is just kind of do your research
beforehand identify what kind of role
you're looking for if you're someone
who's only worked in customer experience
like don't go looking for a software
developer job your chances of success
there are next to zero
and the other thing is don't apply to a
bunch of different roles at companies
i say them laugh because i'm 25 i
recently graduated college when i
graduated i had no clue what i wanted to
do so i would literally just go on
linkedin and like look at companies that
were interesting you know nike under
armour whatever
and go apply to like 10 different roles
at the companies
turns out that's a pretty ineffective
strategy
so kind of narrow down what you're
looking for and kind of how to align
with your skill set
if your skill set isn't suited towards
what you want to do then take the
initiative on your own and go you know
do a boot camp go build up some
experience build up a portfolio that you
can kind of showcase to these companies
and that's like the most interesting
thing so the advice i always give job
seekers is like do the job before you
get the job right which is if you want
to be a salesperson if you show up to
the interview and you're like have these
three leads that i found for you guys
they want to talk to someone here at the
company who should i introduce them to
if you're the person hiring like i think
you're going to be pretty good at this
like you know we should we should find a
role for you but also there's other
things where uh in some way it used to
be like resumes mattered so what school
did you go to what was your degree did
you what was your gpa like all that type
of stuff now if somebody shows up and
like i got 50 000 followers on twitter
and i talk only about i don't know
customer service uh you know uh best
practices
a customer service uh role you're likely
to be pretty good at it right like
you've shown the the proficiency in it
or the knowledge base like what have you
seen people do there that's pretty cool
yeah what i think it comes down to is
like de-risking the hire
so when you come with a portfolio or you
come with leads you know the hiring
manager wants to see that you can do the
job and so i've been on both sides i've
applied and then
i've hired and the people that really
show the initiative to write the cover
letter to show genuine interest in the
company and then come prepared
you know to the interview here's my
portfolio here are some leads it really
you know lets the hiring manager know
that the person can do the job well yeah
when you start to think about uh things
people can do to learn more like where
do you normally send folks from like a
learning just hey i need to get my
experience and my knowledge base up
before i actually start to apply yeah if
you want to work in the industry i think
you have to be on twitter i think that's
step number one and then from there
start with the free resources you know
follow people like you follow people
like sailor
follow the people that are pushing out
you know quality content uh you know go
down the youtube rabbit hole watch
different podcasts sign up for
newsletters just kind of absorb as much
free content as you can first and then
once you kind of have that baseline
level understanding that's when i think
you can go you know take the next step
continue to network we have our training
program that's really good for
networking and getting right in front of
the right people at companies um the
cryptoacademy.io
and we have a career day where these
companies literally come in they pitch
students uh on why they should come work
for them they literally tell them hey
here's what we look for in applicants
here's what you should and shouldn't do
in the application process
and just really puts you kind of ahead
of of the curve
in comparison to to other applicants and
so when you see people
be successful how long does this take is
this a
one week process it does take a whole
year like what would you say the average
transition time is yeah it really just
depends we've seen people go through our
program specifically and then land a job
within a couple of days
and there's some people that you know
they couldn't leave their job you know
for a couple months to even potentially
a couple years
um one guy comes to mind he works now
across the river he was formerly at usaa
uh he was in like our third cohort which
is basically was a year ago
and um he wasn't able to leave his job
he wanted to stay there for whatever
reasons he couldn't relocate etc
and then only recently he accepted a
sweet job at cross river twitter has
almost become linkedin to some degree uh
what do you see people do there
successfully in terms of using that
platform yeah i hate to to my own horn
but uh i have a great story there but i
think just being yourself on twitter um
you know if you're a meme guy create
memes if you're a content guy you know
put out quality threads and things like
that
but the thing that's unique about
twitter is it allows you to essentially
kind of be in the same virtual room as
super successful people that you
wouldn't otherwise be in rooms with
so you can you know dm people you can at
people and you know it's really just the
ultimate networking tool in my opinion
and in crypto specifically people are a
lot more receptive to responding to
stuff as opposed to linkedin myself
included if someone adds me on linkedin
they send me a message i'm terrible at
responding to it but i'm much better at
responding to twitter dms for whatever
reason uh when you start to think about
uh age that's the question that i get
all the time is like is this only for
young people are there older folks like
what do you see there in terms of who
has success who doesn't does age matter
at all yeah no i don't think age matters
at all we have that's a pretty common
question that people ask is like hey i'm
in my 40s 50s 60s i'm super interested
in this i realize bitcoin is the future
how do i get involved
and the thing i tell them is one kind of
the anecdotes or stories that i kind of
shared earlier
but two is like start producing some
content you don't necessarily have to
have a job in the space
to contribute to the industry and
oftentimes contributing to the industry
you know via newsletter podcast etc um
leads to more opportunities too so i
always tell those people look it's never
too late to get started but just start
you know putting content out there start
absorbing as much information as you can
and then start applying what about
geographic location like everyone talks
about this whole like move to remote
work is most of the roles remote are
some of them in office like what are you
seeing there and then also like what do
you see from the candidates so far yeah
there's this new concept that like
latitudes matter more than anything and
it's basically time zones right so it's
more
location agnostic and more so you know
can you fit into uh the certain time
zone that the job requires you to but
oftentimes these companies are just
looking for top talent kind of
regardless of where they are so what
people are saying is look i don't care
if you live in let's say new york city
or in san francisco what i care is can
be plus or minus you know two or three
hours from a specific time zone so if
you're on the west coast uh and we're an
east coast company it's three hours
perfect uh or vice versa but it may be
harder if let's say it's a company based
in singapore and you're in the united
states where there's you know much more
significant time uh uh kind of conflict
if you will yeah correct uh uber no
sorry airbnb is a good example where i
think they recently just opened up and
said hey you guys can work from wherever
we just want you know the best talent so
um coinbase they don't have a
headquarters and there's a number of
other companies in the industry that are
pretty much location agnostic and they
just want talent yeah what about pay
like are these jobs paying more than
let's say their counterparts and other
tech companies are they paying more than
like working at like a small business
what do you see there they're paying
enough to lure away the top talent from
a lot of the top companies but um i
think a lot of the job seekers you know
realize the upside you know in potential
equity and things like that um and it's
just much more exciting than wearing a
suit and tie every day and you know
dreading work it's actually more fun
more engaging you're working in an
industry that you believe in and you're
passionate about you know so to answer
your question yes the pay is is good
across the board but also there's the
added benefit of equity and also just
enjoying work in general yeah it does
seem like people are are maybe happier
right and they don't feel like it's as
much of a job as like hey this is fun uh
the pay as you mentioned probably is
higher uh is that what's leading to a
lot of like the brain drain on wall
street if you will as well where
basically people are saying hey i'm
super interested in finance in general
this is a new form of finance or a new
kind of corner of finance uh i can't do
this stuff at my existing job so why not
go get paid to do it you know full-time
yeah i think the the metric that's
exciting to a lot of people is that
overlay of like where we are with
bitcoin adoption in comparison to where
we were with the internet adoption and
people are kind of realizing maybe they
should skate where the puck is going and
not where the puck has been
um so i think people are just you know
waking up to you know this is the future
and everyone's trying to get involved
one way or the other hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time